my song
uh-huh
okay Rebecca how are you fine you I'm
great
so what time is it it's like 330 now is
I almost fine it's almost 5:00 in the
morning yeah
so I met you how many four years ago
four years ago out here in the Skid Row
in downtown how much money do you make
in a night sometimes you know sometimes
mmm good money sometimes you know like
tonight it's raining yeah why when
you're out here in the cold in the rain
yes your honor every night now really
know how many gonna job this is like a
part-time where's your other job and
what do you do really yeah and when
you're housekeeping you dress as a man
or as well yes you're all woman all
woman yeah no not really
mostly well not yet yes that's cool
and how long have you been doing this
how long about eighteen eighteen years
how much money you making a night
sometimes 300 400 500 100 200 depends
and you pay taxes on that right and your
family my family's all in Mexico Mexico
do they know that you're a woman yeah
how they feel about that cuz Latin
American families don't they're not so
wild about that yeah I've seen a
beautiful thank you thank you you're
what 22 23 what years old at which I
apply right now like 42 years you're 42
yeah you're great you're a blonde yes I
like blondes
show me what you're wearing tonight I
want to see what you're wearing a very
short skirt
so how would we be out here you'll be on
your toes I've already worked for four
to six 46 that's the that's all that you
are that's enough to me why not earlier
in the evening why do you wait till 4:00
a.m. I was I was sleeping watching TV so
you wake up and this is your I worked
out two or three in the morning I'll be
written like a 1 hour to eat there let's
go to work yeah I mean from here you go
where and I go to my house to relax
sleep be ready for cleaning my house do
laundry to be ready first start working
Monday to Friday
excellent and then the guys that pick
you up or nicer there yes yeah but there
what kind of guys so they they're kind
and gentle or they're kind of crazy and
drunk or their tummy is crazy it was
once it's drunk and drugs I think it's
you know and there they hives we're
mocking way but he stole drinking beer
all the time
yeah and there
all kind of the white the black Derek
I'm black
why Mexicans and sounds Chinese me a
little bit yes but the most insolent a
Latino guys saluting and they're looking
for yes and you're probably married what
what are your dreams we're going to be
in five in five years
drink no where would you like to be with
your life would you like to be living in
Beverly Hills would you like to do
Hollywood next moving Hollywood yeah
close to my job that's what I work in
Hollywood Hollywood Highland yeah i
working for LGBT Center Center used to
live downtown
I live on 601 out the by the west side
yeah I gave you I think I gave you a
ride home yes excellent yes well thank
you so much for talking with me no
problem anytime you want something
[Music]
thanks for the offer